Love.
Rage.
Fear.
The grip of a strong emotion can seem to crush all reason.
So, are we doomed to be ruled by whatever feeling is strongest at the moment?
Some ancient philosophers feared that that might be the case.
Plato thought love made people act like insane slaves.
The Greeks thought emotions need to be trained and directed by reason...
...in order to free the mind.
But 17th century philosopher Baruch Spinoza thought having the right emotions at the right time...
...could help drive us to our goals.
Emotions could be a way of linking our desire to survive...
...with behaviors that make sure that we do.
Today, psychologists agree with Spinoza and believe that emotions are middlemen...
...between motivations and behavior.
But emotions don't turn humans into puppets.
We have a much more developed neocortex than apes and other animals,...
...which is thought to let us experience more complex emotions.
It also lets us suppress an impulse when we want to.
For example, we can delay gratification if we think we'll get a bigger reward later.
Our research investigates how emotions and behavior interact...
...because when you're overcome by an emotion, you do feel like a bit of a puppet.